[Musique]
à qui appartient la lune à tout le monde
sans doute on est bien sur l'article 11
de l'accord régissant les activités des
états sur la lune et les autres corps
célestes se lit comme suit
la lune peut faire l'objet d'aucune
appropriation nationale par proclamation
de souveraineté ni par voie
d'utilisation ou d'occupation ni par
aucun autre moyen donc voilà
personne ne peut posséder la lune mais
ce que ça se pourrait que ce soit un peu
plus compliqué que ça nous savons que
seulement sept pays ont ratifié le
traité
l'autriche le chili le maroc les pays
bas le pérou les philippines et
l'uruguay l'orgueilleux ça veut dire que
les 192 autres nations de la planète
peuvent s'être pris territoire sur la
lune comme bon leur semble
probablement pas il existe un autre
document nommé sept fois traitées et
principes des nations unies relatifs à
l'espace extra atmosphérique ou au lit
clairement à l'article 2 l'espace
extra-atmosphérique y compris la lune et
les autres corps célestes ne peut faire
l'objet d'appropriation nationale par
proclamation de souveraineté ni par voie
d'utilisation ou d'occupation ni par
aucun autre moyen les deux extraits ce
récent mettrent en juin une des seule
différence c'est que le deuxième compte
104 et amant la vienne star mais nous
avons ici la réponse à notre question
personne ne peut s'approprier un
territoire sur la lune attendez un peu
la lune ne peut faire l'objet d'aucune
appropriation nationale
ce que c'est très triste dit quoi que ce
soit concernant les particuliers non
allons donc tous exploités la lune mais
en effet les deux traités ne sont pas
clairs au sujet de la propriété privée
de l'espace ce qui donne inévitablement
l'opportunité à certaines personnes de
profiter du système
en 1953 un avocat et poète chilien ne
m'effleure nos gars à dover devenait
célèbre faisant légalement une
proclamation officielle affirmant qu'il
possédait la lune
bien entendu personne ne le prenaient au
sérieux mais la légende raconte tout de
même que le président des états unis de
l'époque
ritchen l'excellent lui aurait demandé
la permission pour atterrir sur la lune
en 1969
bien que je doute de la véracité de
cette légende il existe tout de même une
question morale
derrière tout ça selon moi il existe
deux motivations principales qui nous
incite nous les humains à explorer la
première que l'on peut qualifier de
qualifier de plus humaine et la
satisfaction qui apporte l'exploration
et la découverte à notre curiosité
autrement dit c'est notre curiosité peur
celle qui nous pousse à apprendre et
découvrir peu importe les autres
circonstances
et puis vient la deuxième motivation
celle ci est un peu plus universel c'est
à dire qu'elle s'applique pas seulement
à l'exploration
on parle évidemment de l'appât du gain
bien entendu c'est deuxième motivation
est tout autant humaines que la première
dans le sens où elle était train sact au
caractère de l'homme et de la femme mais
pas nécessairement dans le sens
l'adjectif humain a une connotation
semblable à l'adjectif altruiste
transportons nous maintenant en 1962
quelques années avant le fameux pas de
géant pour l'humanité
alors que le président john f kennedy
prononcé quelques mots qui inspira
l'amérique toute entière dans son fameux
discours annonçant que les états unis
entreprenait un voyage sur la lune
je cite l'homme dans sa quête de
connaissances et de progrès et
déterminée et rien ne peut l'empêcher
d'avancer
l'exploration de l'espace fera nous
embarquons pour explorer ce nouvel océan
car il ya de nouvelles connaissances à
acquérir de nouveaux droits à conquérir
ils doivent être conquis utilisé pour le
progrès de tous les peuples serait
peut-être intéressant de noter qu'alors
que les états unis la fête les
astronautes déposer une plaque sur la
lune signé par le président excelle dans
ce même pays bombarder le sud est de
l'asie avec plus de 7 millions de tonnes
d'explosifs comme l'avait si bien dit
carlos eagle nous nous félicitions de
notre humanité
nous n'allions faire du mal à personne
sur une roche sans vie
mais jeff qui a dit nous embarquons pour
explorer ce nouvel océan
car il ya de nouvelles connaissances à
acquérir aujourd'hui et même à l'époque
on savait la réelle motivation qui me
motivait l'urss et les états unis pour
pour explorer l'espace c'était
l'emplacement stratégique de celui ci la
la nécessité de posséder les sports
c'était le désir de supériorité c'était
donc l'appât du gain qui motivait ces
deux nations en guerre
bien qu'on déguise en celle ci pour la
faire passer comme comme une quête de
connaissances et de progrès aussi bien
que le drapeau posé sur la lune était
beaucoup plus important que les extraits
de roche rapporté imaginons un peu à
quoi ressemblera demain si tout ce que
l'on valorise le drop
ce qu'on attendrait dans la rhétorique
de mots drapeau est meilleur que le tien
ya peut-être des frontières dans
l'espace
les douanes des traités de libre échange
et de protectionnisme en différentes
dont des tirs et il nouvelles des
nouvelles religions certaines arrière
comme du le jedi et l'autre le capitaine
spock et aussi peut-être certaines
régions récurrents plus d'espacé
requérir un plus grand territoire parce
qu'ils pensent qu'ils sont trop près
d'une étoile et ça les aveugles ou bien
parce qu'ils sont trop près d'un trou
noir et le voit rien intel futur pour
l'espace où son exploration est motivée
par l'appât du gain de pouvoir de profit
de quelque chose juste pour l'avoir ou
des travers de notre ne serait qu'une
copie du modèle terrain actuel l'espace
c'est une zone de coopération
internationale notre zone de dépassement
humain gardons là comme ce gars dont le
unique et indépendant ou situation
géopolitique se déroulant sur terre et
puis c'est ce qu'on fait déjà un futur
pour l'espace où son exploration est
motivée par la curiosité et déjà entamé
aujourd'hui pro bowl et le télescope le
plus puissant jamais construit mais en
on va lancer de rejoindre un autre
télescope spatial à la fine pointe de la
technologie
j'ai besoin de bien plus gros bol enfin
il sera la taille d'un terrain de tennis
alors qu'un robot de la taille d'un
autobus scolaire environ et pour avoir
en moyenne 70% plus de lumière que ras
bord avec ça on va être capable de voir
les premières étoiles les premières
galaxies du cosmos si vous le permettent
non seulement de voir plus loin dans
notre univers que jamais mais également
plus tôt gilles jouer est littéralement
une machine à voyager dans le temps
puisque la lumière voyage à 300 mille
kilomètres par seconde
plus loin on regarde le plus tôt on voit
ça va nous permettre de répondre à des
questions comme la tille de la vie
ailleurs que sur terre et pour tous à
presque 12 milliards de dollars
mais c'est bien sûr que ça vaut 1 sur la
boutique aux biens des connaissances oui
mais en matière d'emprunt est ce que les
connaissances la conscience la
technologie l'inspiration et la beauté
pure que peuvent rapporter les images de
james webb peuvent alors beaucoup plus
il peut faire beaucoup plus de bien à
l'humanité compense suffit de regarder
les images de son prédécesseur robot moi
quand je regarde ça inutile de vous dire
que ça me coupe le souffle
comment est ce qu'on peut voir de telles
choses
tout ce que je vois moi quand je regarde
des petits points lumineux mais sans
doute qu'on y trouve une richesse
incroyable ce qu'on creuse plus
profondément
mais c'est un jardin et d'imagination et
de sagesse laissez moi vous dire le fait
qu'on ait réussi des financières tel
projet à 12 milliards de dollars
sachant que le télescope ne sera même
pas capable de lancer des bombes
nucléaires de l'espace et que le seul
laser dont il est équipé sarah mieux
voir ça c'est ce que j'appelle du
progrès par la science enfin et c'est le
cas de le dire
enfin les images prises par le télescope
sera plus importante que les drapeaux à
coller sur celui ci et je vous dis que
c'est dans un futur pour l'espace comme
ceux que je vive c'est dans un tel futur
que je me vois marcher sur mars
l'espace c'est notre héritage commun
donc son exploration devrait se faire
pour tous
oui mais pourquoi tu vas les surmas me
dit on chez vous 2 à 4 ans - ta femme
est loin de tout en plus j'ai des
lunettes
si tu vois même pas choisi en allant sur
mars ou simplement fixe à ceux ci comme
but à long terme
j'inspire des jeunes à poursuivre une
carrière en science je contribue au
développement de technologies jamais
pensé auparavant
mais par dessus tout je contribue à
assurer la survie de l'espèce humaine si
j'avais la terre est menacée par un
astéroïde par exemple ce qui est très
probable d'ailleurs on doit s'assurer de
pouvoir conserver la vie après tout on
est composé de la même matière que
l'univers on est finie même d'atomes qui
était dans le coeur des étoiles et des
millions d'années votre corps vous est
probablement composée d'atomes provenant
de différentes étoiles sommes donc le
cosmos en soi mais le cosmos capable de
réfléchir sur lui-même
je te prie village et aller sur mars
nous permettra de garder ce privilège
sans culture astronautes je me propose
donc pour être le gardien des privilèges
demain tout comme lots de masques
son but à lui comme le mien est beaucoup
plus grand que lui même il n'est rien
d'autre que de faire des humains une
espèce interplanétaire jusque vers ce
gars là ils financent et développe un
projet pour bâtir une colonie sur mars
et il prévoit même devancé la nasa dans
la course pour la planète rouge
certains pensent qu'ils font mais
attendez il est capable de beaucoup de
choses
fondateur de tesla spector l'aspect sexe
c'est un passionné il en masque si tu
m'écoutes en ce moment notre que serait
volontaire embarqué l'ancien de diffuser
pour me rendre sur mars
n'importe quand sauf la semaine
prochaine les deux examens
mais on lutte pour la même chose est en
lutte pour la même chose depuis
d'ailleurs quelques temps ce rêve
résidents mois depuis l'été 2008 quand
j'avais huit ans après est allé au camp
spatial pour la première fois depuis ce
temps l'homme à flamme intérieure s'est
développée j'essaie de prendre des
actions concrètes qui va me permettre de
réaliser mon rêve
enfin j'essaie de rendre mon chemin vers
mon rêve autant plaisant que son attaque
c'est un 3 août une des raisons pourquoi
je suis ici à vous parler de ça mais
détrompez vous je suis pas motivé par la
chance d'être celle est parce que j'ai
fait un télex québec et bien par toutes
les opportunités là connaissances et les
expériences que mon chemin peut
m'apporter a tant que futurs astronautes
je me propose donc pour être le gardien
de la véritable nature humaine de faire
de l'espace eu lieu d'émerveillement
pour tout le monde de faire de lui un
refuge pour n'importe qui qui sont moins
bien je vais tenter de le rendre sur la
une des journaux
une fois de plus mais par dessus tout je
vais tenter de révéler la science et et
le cosmos assez réelle admirateurs via
ses réels profiteurs c'est à dire la
communauté nous sommes de la poussière
des toiles dit hubert reeves alors
tâchons de rester éveillé et
conscientisant nous sur le fait que nous
sommes ce que des atomes d'hydrogène
fond après 14 milliards d'années
c'est fascinant merci beaucoup à nasa
[Applaudissements]